hello there my name is Rhonda I'm candle
material can we talk to you today about
my ideas on climate change the question
is how do we tackle climate change
unique stations since the Kyoto Protocol
will expire next year I would suggest
that the climate change is assessed
attacks at the micro level at the
grassroots level the ideas and new
commercial for that are reading at the
at the city or community double on where
stakeholders are brought together to
exchange ideas on how to reduce our
carbon emissions carbon emissions that
for all of our ethics of climate change
that's what by putting together all the
stakeholders exchanging ideas but 101
things and we do every day and how we
can have been better to reduce climate
change and it can be simple things like
saying your bicycle for mortar schools
instead of taking the guard of taking
public transport changing the way you
you handle your your garbage that you
give out less methane emissions very now
your air conditioning because turning
off your all of this I look like comics
if you're sitting on standby online and
so on the ideas are endless but the
impact of it because when you start
organizing it athlete at the community
doesn't you are able to make our
differences and we were able to build
since it's got your emissions
immediately other cities are the major
source of carbon emissions in this world
and also slow down the pace of energy
demands or less power stations will have
to be built and these days where most of
our stations are built still fired by
fossil fuels that too makes a big
difference so you don't have to wait for
it politicians you don't have a way for
a new protocol you can take things in
your own hands and move its grassroot
level as the other part of this is
educational putting the yeah
not making the teacher who really teach
children about the importance of
reducing carbon emissions fighting try
to change scream all of these people
eater uh attitudes and behaviors will
make a difference these things children
grow up to be encoders up tomorrow and
that's where we'll see real political
change we have real permanent program
fighter approach to reducing it
eliminate my life so your thanks